A 2018 Pew poll reports that a majority
of Americans on both the right and the left
say that higher education is headed
in the wrong direction – and they're spot on.
On the left, respondents say tuition
costs are too high.
While college presidents have made
excuses and pointed fingers,
after-inflation costs have more than doubled
over the past 30 years, as colleges
cheerfully spent heavily on amenities,
athletics, and bureaucracy.
On the right, those who see things going south
point to politicized classrooms and
restrictions on campus speech. Behind the
many instances where Republican
sentiment has been treated as a thought
crime on campus is the inconvenient
reality that liberal faculty outnumber
conservatives five to one,
and that one in three sociologists admit
they'd be less likely to hire a new professor
if he or she was a Republican.
While there's little evidence that
public censure will prompt needed change
on campus, it's reassuring to know that
Americans on both sides of the aisle are
seeing things clearly.
Do you think America's colleges are headed in the
wrong direction? Let us know in your comments.
Also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.